how's it going rose you can barely
[ __ ] see me there we go welcome to the
burning room I have no [ __ ] idea what
this is it seems really weird cuz it was
linked to me on Twitter never I was like
up for you to play this and I'll IRL cuz
I play but it goes to full screen mode
and I'm like why and then it's like
burning room and it looks kind of cool
and I'm like what is it actually cool
and then I guess we're gonna find out
people I hear the best horror game right
YouTube that'd be good you should
consider yourself lucky you're gonna
have a nice afternoon you and me baby
let's kick the play I don't oh nice are
we watching a video
what them oh god what the [ __ ] oh the
hell was i doing up there I don't know I
was an orangutan so I can guy this is
watch this is [ __ ] creepy man oh yeah
hello umm sides see that I was busy
burning and the ceiling okay I don't
jump in my face but [ __ ] is she doing
alright don't I'm gonna look over here
now or never got some cards what can i
SS is no nut why did I say okay but
clean your face first my god don't you
don't do that you don't do that it was
obvious but I felt so hard for it
Oh God alright let's go inside the box
apparently
that's not a real baby you [ __ ]
this is some weird ad commercial ad
commercial really oh god what the fine
like don't smoke in your house or some
[ __ ]
poor lamp Oh God you didn't have to you
don't have to if it's bad is in that
room hey don't there's no way up or
lamps what it let's click on it
gotta get itchy when I gets good good
snips on my buddy oh it's a [ __ ] again
so I doubted me to call your [ __ ] you
just don't turn around hi oh god I don't
want to click on her attention
nice that's wonderful god what is
happening
I do anything to deserve this look at
this music I'm alive miracle oh [ __ ]
you're not clicking on you they look so
hot don't exactly god I don't like
firefighters like one of the best
inventions ever let's go upstairs
I don't know what to feel about this all
right all I know is that business makes
me itchy man oh god what the hell what
is that it what did I just witness I
failed that I win that I failed in it
what happened let alone the stain her
face was burning and I'm like look what
the burning room that was a short is our
game ever and I have no idea what the
[ __ ] just happened I think there was a
lot of subliminal messages in there like
don't poop unless there's a fire or
something
yeah I think that's it wonderful
why would I restart though all right you
bros you brothers leave your thoughts in
the comments I have no [ __ ] idea
but anyway leave it like me know
watching it's just kind of gone by the
day else
I see brows in the next episode say
awesome